good morning believe nation today's
message is no excuses over to you Astro
teller I wake up every morning TV go no
excuses no victim mentality the world
owes you nothing the world might come
help you but I wouldn't count on it and
if you start from the feeling that you
need the world to participate in order
for you to be successful at taking on
this new thing that you're considering
doing you're right to be scared a mite I
wouldn't count on it though but if you
start from the perspective that the
world owes you nothing which it doesn't
and then it is not likely to bring you
any particular help you have nothing to
lose because really isn't that for every
one of the people you brought on to team
isn't that how you want them to feel
when they report to you you know what
excuses that doesn't mean that you can't
fail or that they can't ever fail but
right when you're starting you have
nothing to lose right when you're a huge
company you can spend ninety nine
percent of your time worrying how not to
mess up the billion dollar your money
hoes you've created but you don't have a
billion dollar your money hoes right now
you have nothing so you can't lose spend
ninety nine percent of your time
imagining what would happen if things
went well and planning for that because
there's no downside it's like a free
option on an adventure having no excuses
is is great for your
for when you do have excuses there's
always like something you're going to
want to do but like everyone has an
excuse there's always going to be an
excuse but looking in a way that like
there are no excuses like something will
always happen like something something
will like either you'll be busy or like
something will happen that you can
always give yourself an excuse looking
at it like there are no excuses is just
another obstacle like you have to go do
it is a great way to accomplish like
anything you want yeah I think every
major breakthrough have had in my life
has been because I've gone I've smashed
through a limiting personal belief where
I felt like I can't be successful
because of this right I can't sell
software to these guys because I'm only
19 years old these and they're three
times my age right they won't take me
seriously every time I make that big
breakthrough I realized that that's just
a story that I'm telling myself that's
just something that I've made up that is
not a natural truth and so it's uh
taking accountability for your life and
stopping the blame on other things don't
blame the economy don't blame your
friends or your family or don't blame
you know you didn't get an education
university you didn't you didn't have
parents who are rich like these are all
stories that just hold you back and as
long as you continue to believe them
then it's going to continue to hold you
back and when you take accountability
and acceptance for your life you'll
notice a certain make the big rivers so
the question today today is what's your
biggest excuse thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso okay
this prey so give me go